what's up y'all I'm here to talk about
the Callisto protocol after playing
about 90 minutes of the game during a
preview event
a lot of what I played was expected the
setting and enemy designs are certainly
unnerving but in a way I've seen before
quite literally a week prior when John
Luke and I were previewing the Dead
Space remake but the Callisto protocol
stands out and what it does differently
from its spiritual successor that it
injects a compelling melee combat system
into a survival horror game
many survival horror games keep their
monsters more than an arm's length away
allowing you to keep them at Bay with a
handgun plasma cutter camera or some
other manner of clicking and shooting
the Callisto protocol breaks that mold
amping its tension by encouraging you to
aggressively deal with whatever gross
monster you're fighting and that makes
for some fun combat developed by
Striking Distance Studios the Callisto
protocol sees you play as Jacob Lee
who's being kept in Black Iron a prison
located upon Callisto one of Jupiter's
moons Jacob quickly finds himself
needing to escape as a deadly infection
sweeps black Iron transforming the
former human inhabitants into monstrous
mutations referred to as biophages so
far Jacob seems to match the energy of
the male survival horror protagonists
we've seen in recent years often
speaking to himself when figuring out
where to go for his next objective or
cursing out the monsters he's going up
against following a specially harrowing
encounter he certainly cuts the tension
a tad more than I would like but the
Callisto protocol's atmosphere is so
unsettling feeling that it claws its way
back under your skin quickly enough
instead of cinematic cut scenes and
regular conversations between Jacob and
the other human survivors the Callisto
protocol seems to build most of its
story with audio logs some of which
detail truly unsettling events these are
all optional so you can miss out on a
lot of lore if you just speed through
the events of the story more so than the
story what struck me most about the
Callisto protocol is its combat lots of
survival horror protagonists are either
trained in the use of firearms or
everyday people trying to make do with
makeshift weapons that can keep the
monsters at Bay regardless there's a
sense of precision to combat in these
games whether it means pulling off the
perfect headshot or lining up a limb to
sever similarly the clista protocol
prioritizes Precision but by putting
that emphasis on melee combat you
suddenly need to pull off exact
movements in the heat of a bra instead
of from a distance it's not unlike the
sensation of playing a game like for
Honor albeit in a Sci-Fi setting you're
also fighting some truly gross looking
monsters and a lot of of ways the
biophages are very similar to dead space
as Necromorphs both enemies are highly
mutated creatures that stretch and
contort the human form into something
while monstrous manages to still be
terrifyingly recognizable the cluster
protocol manages to break free from dead
space's Shadow by changing how you deal
with this threat forcing you to act with
Precision within lunging range which is
a whole different kind of trepidation to
deal with this does lessen the Fear
Factor of these creatures a bit though a
zombie or Necromorph or ghostly Spirit
that's being kept at a distance can be
viewed in all its ghastly Glory it's far
harder when the enemy is right in your
face I never really had the chance to be
horrified at the enemy design in the
Callisto protocol given how in your face
the biophages are though their
aggressive nature certainly makes for
some tense combat encounters
mechanically the clista protocol uses a
combat system composed of attacks and
Dodges that are meant to encourage you
to be hyper aggressive against whatever
you're fighting Jacob also comes
equipped with a firearm but ammo is
limited and the gun doesn't do nearly as
much damage as your melee attacks safer
when an enemy is momentarily stunned
when this occurs you have a brief moment
to quickly pull out your gun and fire at
the highlighted weak spot doing so deals
a tremendous amount of damage to
whatever you're fighting even
potentially carving off the limbs or
head of your foe this can alter your
situation by quite a bit a biophage
without legs will have to slowly crawl
its way towards you for example there
was one moment during my preview that I
hope is an indication that we'll see
more strategic dismemberment in the full
release when I can only imagine is a
cheeky reference back to Dead Space
there is a moment in the Callisto
protocol where you find a message
Written in Blood on the wall that says
shoot the tentacles this event precedes
encountering biophages with
tentacle-line stomachs that will mutate
into more powerful forms once weakened
to deal with them you have to damage
them enough to start mutating which
begins with their stomach tentacles
erupting from their body in this moment
you have precious time to shoot and
destroy the tentacles stopping the
transformation it adds a bit more
strategy to the combat since you want to
keep a little distance from the
biophages that can mutate just so you
can actually see when the process is
starting if they get too close the
animation is oftentimes lost in the
flurry of lens
initially I approached the Callisto
protocol much like dead space Resident
Evil or The Evil Within carefully
weighing the situation and warily
approaching each fight trying to take
out one enemy at a time and then pulling
back to reassess that saw me die a lot
because you can't instantly heal in the
Callisto protocol to heal Jacob crouches
takes out a syringe and slowly injects
himself you're a Sitting Duck for a good
while in a game where the enemies might
Lumber towards you even within a group a
healing system like this would be no
problem but enemies in the Callisto
protocol hit hardest when they're in
your face and do all they can to close
the distance on you quickly with a very
little room to breathe I quickly found
that it is best to heal after a fight
has ended not during that means you also
have to hit hard and fast against every
enemy in the group ending the battle as
quickly as you can in this way the
cluster protocol encourages you to turn
the tables on your foes you you have to
be the monster in the room pursuing the
biophages with murderous abandon you
want to be overly Reckless of course as
that'll see you end up dead in no time
but I found far more success in the
Callisto protocol when I threw caution
to the wind and risked a few hits to
land half a dozen of my own instead of
using the telekinetic grip device to
grab objects and throw them at enemies I
most often used to pull enemies towards
me and land an early strike during an
especially harrowing moment in a very
narrow hallway featuring a murderous
parade of enemies I only succeeded when
I decided to push forward through the
deadly Onslaught and meet the biophages
head on quickly bashing their first few
into the walls to give me the precious
seconds necessary to dodge the blows of
those who came right after and then
start fighting them all at once sending
each in quick succession playing it safe
and being careful only gave the enemies
enough time to Bunch together and
overwhelm me but being aggressive helped
turn the tables on them the combat isn't
all that scary the violence in the game
is brutal and super gross but in a way
that feels geared towards producing
shock as opposed to genuine fear the
Callisto protocol is certainly a
survival experience with scarce
resources and hard-hitting enemies
always encouraging you to forage for
ammo or a health pack but the section I
played lacked the unnerving sense of
discomfort I love in my favorite
survival horror games I never really
felt like Jacob was ever on the back
foot the dude is an exceptionally
capable brawler and once I got used to
the combat I was holding my own against
the biophages I never felt like I was a
dominant Force but I wasn't just some
guy totally out of his League either
this isn't necessarily a bad thing as I
really enjoyed what I played of the
Callisto protocols combat I just want to
warn folks that if you're expecting the
Callisto protocol to be this terrifying
horror experience that's not the vibe I
got from the snippet of the game I
played the setting is spooky the
monsters are gross but this game doesn't
seem to match the truly horrific tone of
its initial announcement trailer granted
almost the entire preview was combat
Gauntlet after combat Gauntlet I didn't
have much chance to see elements of the
cluster protocol Story play out or
whether or not the game featured much in
the way of puzzles or horrifying
Mysteries to solve and most notably the
section I play didn't feature
opportunities to see how the game's
stealth moments worked if they're there
these elements could be where a lot of
the cluster protocol's Fear Factor come
from there was one moment during the
session where I was able to sneak around
as I slowly Crouch walked past a robotic
guard and that was nerve-wracking but
the section came and went in a Flash
hardly enough time to get a good idea as
to how the Callisto Protocol Stealth
sections play and feel more broadly but
is just enough time to offer an
intriguing Glimpse at what could be
quite scary something that I did notice
during that small stealth section that
gives me pause is that you have very
little control over the camera in the
clista protocol making it very difficult
to see anything over Jacob's left
shoulder which is where his character
model takes up the most screen real
estate you really only have peripheral
vision on your right personally I'm
worried that this could result in
frustrating death death specifically
during the stealth segments as a big
part of stealth games is the ability to
look around and plan I imagine that's
much harder to do in a game like the
Callisto protocol given the limits of
the camera thankfully the camera didn't
create any huge problems for me during
the combat but I think this restriction
will be something to look out for once
the full game launches and we get a
chance to play through the stealth
sections especially if there happen to
be scenarios where if you're not careful
you just die
I see what's going on
the terrifying possibility of instacle
deaths aside I came away from the
Callisto protocol feeling tense from the
pressure of the enclosed setting and
more than a little unnerved by The
Game's enemy design but I wasn't scared
or terrified of the situation I played
through Jacob is a beast once you get
the hang of his Dodges and melee strikes
and pulling foes into your Mighty swing
makes quick enough work of them to make
you feel at least on par with these
monsters at least in this one level the
Calisto protocol seems to be a survival
game that prioritizes the challenge of
its action-focused combat aiming to
create horror and the prospect that you
have to get into an enemy's Grill to do
the most damage and suffer disgusting
death animation if you mess up once
you've grasped how combat Works however
you seem to be one of the scariest
monsters in the prison obviously since
it's just a preview and I only got to
play through a presumably small section
of the game it's way too early to make a
definitive call on the kalista protocol
a lot of what could make the game more
horrifying and scary might be tucked
away in parts of the Callisto protocol
I've yet to see we won't know until the
game comes out but thankfully we don't
have long to wait because the Calista
protocol Launches on December 2nd for
more on the Callisto protocol you can
read through my written preview of The
Game on gamespot.com which includes
quotes and insight from my interview
with Striking Distance Studios CEO Glenn
Schofield and if you're in the mood for
more survival horror I'd recommend
watching your video previews of the Dead
Space remake and the Resident Evil 4
remake
[Music]